This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Dance like no one is watching. Sing like you are alone in the shower. Be yourself. Everyone else is already taken. Countless aphorisms remind us that as we move through life, we have a choice. We can pretend and disguise who we are, or we can be true to ourselves. What does it mean to be ourselves no matter what they say,
这里是《Hidden Brain》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。像没人注视那样跳舞。像独自在淋浴间那样歌唱。做你自己。其他人已经有人做了。无数的格言提醒我们，当我们走过人生时，我们有选择。我们可以伪装和掩饰真实的自己，或者我们可以忠于自我。无论别人怎么说，做回自己意味着什么？
as the musician Gordon Sumner, better known as Sting, once instructed us? Don't we all contain multitudes? Is there really only one true self? And even if there is, how wise is it to always reveal ourselves? As social creatures, heavily dependent on the people around us, does it really make sense to ignore how others see us and march to our own drummers?
正如音乐家戈登·萨姆纳（更广为人知的名字是斯汀）曾经教导我们的那样？难道我们每个人不都包含着多种自我吗？真的只有一个真实的自我吗？即使有，总是展现真实的自己又有多明智呢？作为社会性动物，严重依赖周围的人，无视他人如何看待我们并坚持走自己的路，真的有意义吗？
The evidence about authenticity seems clearer when the shoe is on the other foot. When we are evaluating other people, most of us are extremely suspicious of people who may not be what they seem. When we discover someone has lied to us, either implicitly or explicitly, we read this as betrayal. We distrust those who say one thing in public and do something else in private. This is why politicians learn to look you in the eye as they speak to you, why they master the art of the firm handshake and the steady voice. This is really me, they are trying to say. What you see is what you get. Wellness 2.0. We'll go beyond the angst surrounding New Year's resolutions
当角色互换时，关于真实性的证据似乎更清晰。当我们评价他人时，我们大多数人对那些可能表里不一的人极其怀疑。当我们发现有人隐晦或明确地对我们撒谎时，我们将其解读为背叛。我们不信任那些在公开场合说一套，私下里做另一套的人。这就是为什么政客们学会了在与你交谈时直视你的眼睛，为什么他们掌握了坚定握手和沉稳语调的艺术。他们试图说：这才是真实的我。你所见即所得。健康2.0。我们将超越围绕新年决心的焦虑，
and answer a deeper question. What does it mean to live well? Over the next few weeks, we'll talk about how to keep your cool during stressful times and how to rise to the occasion during moments of crisis. We'll also help you figure out what you actually want in life and how to embrace the role that chance plays in shaping who you are.
并回答一个更深层的问题。活得好意味着什么？在接下来的几周里，我们将讨论如何在压力时期保持冷静，以及如何在危机时刻挺身而出。我们还将帮助你弄清楚你在生活中真正想要的是什么，以及如何拥抱机遇在塑造你的人生中所扮演的角色。
We begin with what it means and what it takes to live an authentic life. How to be yourself, this week on Hidden Brain. Every day, we are called upon to play many roles. Parent, spouse, employee, neighbor, friend. Some roles may feel like the real us, and some may feel put on, even fake. What are the benefits of aligning who we are on the outside with who we are on the inside, and what are the costs of those two selves
我们从活出真实人生的意义和代价开始。本周的《Hidden Brain》将探讨如何做你自己。每天，我们都被要求扮演许多角色。父母、配偶、员工、邻居、朋友。有些角色可能感觉像是真实的我们，而有些可能感觉是装出来的，甚至是虚假的。将外在的自我与内在的自我保持一致有什么好处，而这两个自我
being out of alignment? Erica Bailey is a social scientist at the University of California, Berkeley. She has long been interested in the science and the subtleties of authenticity. Erica Bailey, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you so much for having me. Erica, when you were growing up, you were very involved in the fundamentalist church that was at the heart of your community.
不一致又有什么代价呢？埃里卡·贝利是加州大学伯克利分校的社会科学家。她长期以来一直对真实性的科学和微妙之处感兴趣。埃里卡·贝利，欢迎来到《Hidden Brain》。非常感谢你的邀请。埃里卡，当你成长时，你非常投入于你社区核心的基要派教会。
What was this church? So this was a small religious group in central Ohio. It was related through my parents and people that they knew. It had all of the earmarks, I would say, of what you would consider a cult in terms of being a very high control group, having really strict ideologies, and a lot of isolation from people who are not part of the group. How much of a role did this church play in your life, do you think, as you were growing up?
这是个什么样的教会？这是一个位于俄亥俄州中部的宗教小团体。它通过我的父母和他们认识的人联系在一起。我想说，它具备了你所认为的邪教的所有特征，比如是一个高控制力的团体，有着非常严格的意识形态，并且与团体外的人有很大的隔绝。你认为这个教会在你成长过程中扮演了多大的角色？
It started off as sort of smaller or a little bit distanced from us. I grew up in Pittsburgh, Pennsylvania, so a couple hours away. It gradually increased to become an incredibly central part of my life. It was a place we would spend hours and hours every week with people from the community in the church itself. And by the time I was 19, 20, I was kind of all in. I was living full-time with people from the group. I was evangelizing on behalf of the group and it really kind of took up my whole identity. I would imagine now you must have had close friends in the group and in fact maybe much of your social community was coming from this group.
起初它离我们比较小或有点距离。我在宾夕法尼亚州的匹兹堡长大，所以离那里有几个小时的路程。它逐渐发展成为我生活中极其核心的一部分。那是一个我们每周会花上数小时与教会社区里的人在一起的地方。到我19、20岁时，我已经完全投入了。我和团体里的人全职住在一起。我代表团体进行传教，它真的占据了我整个身份。我想你当时一定在团体里有亲密的朋友，事实上，也许你的大部分社交圈都来自这个团体。
Almost entirely my social community was this group itself. They really discouraged having outside relationships and really told you or taught you both implicitly and explicitly that this should be your whole life, that this message that they had was so important it was worth sort of forsaking any outside connections that might distract you from what the group was really about. At the time of course, Erica didn't think she was in a cult. Like all of us, she wanted direction in her life, and the church seemed to confidently point the way. Most people are drawn to a group like this, I think, because we are incredibly curious and maybe a little insecure about what is this life all about? What am I all about? What's my purpose? What's my meaning in life? And we're looking for someone who could help provide those
我的社交圈几乎完全是这个团体本身。他们真的不鼓励建立外部关系，并且确实隐晦地和明确地告诉你或教导你，这应该是你的全部生活，他们所拥有的这个信息是如此重要，以至于值得放弃任何可能分散你对团体真正关注点的外部联系。当然，当时埃里卡并不认为自己身处邪教中。像我们所有人一样，她想要人生的方向，而教会似乎自信地指明了道路。我认为大多数人被这样的团体吸引，是因为我们极其好奇，也许对“人生到底是为了什么？”、“我到底是为了什么？”、“我的目标是什么？”、“我人生的意义是什么？”感到有点不安。我们正在寻找能帮助提供这些
answers for us. And the group provided a really appealing idea that we have all of the answers, and if you just stick with us, we'll tell you them. We'll help inform your path. We'll help show you your ideal path. And even better than just your ideal path, this is the path that God has ordained for you. And that's a really appealing message that can help reduce some of these concerns about what does it all mean. In time, however, Erica started to have doubts. For example, she knew people who were gay and in warm and loving relationships, but the church declared gay marriage was wrong. She wasn't quite sure how or whether to speak up.
答案的人。而这个团体提供了一个非常有吸引力的想法，即我们拥有所有的答案，只要你坚持和我们在一起，我们就会告诉你。我们会帮助指引你的道路。我们会帮助展示你理想的道路。而且比仅仅是你的理想道路更好的是，这是上帝为你预定的道路。这是一个非常有吸引力的信息，可以帮助减少一些关于“这一切意味着什么”的担忧。然而，随着时间的推移，埃里卡开始产生怀疑。例如，她认识一些同性恋且处于温暖、充满爱意的关系中的人，但教会宣称同性婚姻是错误的。她不太确定该如何或是否应该说出来。
On the one hand, it was incredibly challenging to feel that I had differing beliefs to the people around me and that voicing those beliefs could get me in trouble or get me sanctioned or at least have a stern talking to. At the same time, I really desperately wanted them to approve me and to accept me and to value me in the group. And so I was willing to sort of not say what I was really thinking or hide those beliefs in exchange for maintaining these relationships that I valued so much. How did the church treat congregants who stepped out of line? There were lots of ways that you would be sort of disciplined, quote unquote, and usually it would
一方面，感觉到自己与周围人的信仰不同，并且表达这些信仰可能会让我陷入麻烦、受到制裁，或者至少被严厉训斥，这极具挑战性。与此同时，我非常渴望他们认可我、接受我，并重视我在团体中的地位。所以我愿意选择不说出我真实的想法，或者隐藏那些信仰，以换取维持这些我非常看重的关系。教会是如何对待那些不守规矩的信徒的？有很多方式让你受到所谓的纪律处分，通常是
be, you know, your disgust and the church leader would mention something that happened in a sermon. So you're sort of, you know that he's talking about you, you feel that shame that everyone must know that you made the wrong choice. Or you had really intense one-on-one conversations where you were reprimanded and told that what you had done was out of alignment, it wasn't the right path, it wasn't the godly path. And frustratingly, those individual conversations could happen at any time. And sort of one thing that you did one day could be right, and that could be the spiritual choice. And then another day, it would be the wrong choice. And so you're always kind of questioning which decisions were right and which decisions were supported. And those
你知道的，你的厌恶，教会领袖会在布道中提到发生的事情。所以你，你知道他在说你，你感到那种羞耻感，觉得每个人一定都知道你做出了错误的选择。或者你会进行非常激烈的一对一谈话，在那里你受到训斥，被告知你所做的事情是不一致的，那不是正确的道路，不是敬虔的道路。令人沮丧的是，这些个人谈话可能随时发生。你某天做的一件事可能是对的，那可能是属灵的选择。而另一天，它又会变成错误的选择。所以你总是会质疑哪些决定是正确的，哪些决定是得到支持的。而那些
who were sort of in the know, would just know the right answers. And what I know now is that was a way to sort of control our behaviors. You never felt like you really were settled or secure. You always were looking for guidance. And that was an incredibly confusing experience. So I understand that you were always academically inclined. Tell me about what happened when you graduated high school and you had to make the choice about whether to go to college. Yeah, I felt very adrift in terms of what the right thing to do is.
知情的人，只会知道正确的答案。而我现在知道，那是一种控制我们行为的方式。你从来没有感到自己真正安定或安全。你总是寻求指导。那是一段极其令人困惑的经历。所以我了解到你一直倾向于学术。告诉我当你高中毕业，必须做出是否上大学的选择时发生了什么。是的，对于什么是正确的事情，我感到非常迷茫。
Because I had sort of disconnected from school, from my peers who maybe were going to colleges or applying to college at the same time, I almost didn't know the right steps to take. And ultimately felt this pressure to follow along with the path that the church had outlined for us, which was to take a year to invest heavily in my faith and to try and bring new people into the group and do that instead of going to college, which was sort of the worldly choice. So even though I always was very bookish, I was very nerdy, I was very inquisitive,
因为我已经与学校、与那些可能同时上大学或申请大学的同龄人脱节了，我几乎不知道该采取什么正确的步骤。最终感到一种压力，要遵循教会为我们规划的道路，那就是花一年时间全身心投入到我的信仰中，并尝试将新人带入团体，而不是去上大学，那被视为世俗的选择。所以即使我一直很爱读书，我很书呆子气，我很好奇，
I always really wanted to go to college, it was sort of implicitly discouraged that that was sort of the lesser path, that was the earthly, worldly path. And what did you do that year? I moved to a small town with a group of people from the church and we sort of set up a satellite group in that town and we went around talking to people about the message of the group and trying to recruit people into our group. I'm wondering whether at some point you started to speak up about the beliefs and practices that you
我一直真的很想上大学，但它被隐晦地劝阻了，认为那是次要的道路，那是属世的、世俗的道路。那一年你做了什么？我和教会的一群人搬到了一个小镇，我们在那个镇上建立了一个卫星小组，我们四处与人们谈论团体的信息，并试图招募人们加入我们的团体。我想知道在某个时刻，你是否开始说出那些你
disagreed with and how that was received by your peers and by the church. What really shook my whole sort of belief system is we had a death in my family. My niece passed away. And it was one of those experiences that sort of jolts you awake. It's really nice to have these ideas that the church gave us about how special we are, how powerful we were, how logically our life path would unfold. And then when this happened, it felt like one of those moments where I looked around to realize, you know, I'd been holding on to sand and I had nothing. And these stories that I had been told about myself, about the world, about the way my
不同意的信仰和做法，以及你的同龄人和教会是如何接受的。真正动摇我整个信仰体系的是我的家庭发生了一起死亡事件。我的侄女去世了。那是那种让你猛然惊醒的经历之一。教会给我们的关于我们有多特别、我们有多强大、我们的人生道路会如何合乎逻辑地展开的想法，听起来确实很好。然后当这件事发生时，感觉就像是我环顾四周意识到，你知道，我一直抓着沙子，我一无所有。这些关于我自己、关于世界、关于我的
life would unfold, were not accurate, or they were empty. And that moment is really when I started to feel like I had to really voice those questions and concerns, and I had to start saying, actually, I don't think I agree with what they just told my sister after her daughter passed. concerns and I had to start saying, actually I don't think I agree with what they just told you know my sister after her daughter passed. You know I don't actually agree with maybe these other stances that are more about how we treat other people. Maybe it's okay to have friends who are not part of the group. Maybe it's okay to think differently about the world and the purpose of life and how people outside the group should be valued and appreciated. That moment was fairly dramatic and things kind of happened quickly after that.
人生会如何展开的故事，是不准确的，或者它们是空洞的。那一刻，我真的开始觉得我必须真正表达出那些问题和担忧，我必须开始说，实际上，我不认为我同意他们刚刚在我侄女去世后对我姐姐说的话。担忧，我必须开始说，实际上我不认为我同意他们刚刚在我侄女去世后对我姐姐说的话。你知道，我实际上可能不同意这些关于我们如何对待他人的其他立场。也许有不是团体成员的朋友也没关系。也许对世界、对人生的目的，以及对团体外的人应该如何被重视和欣赏，有不同的看法也没关系。那一刻相当戏剧性，在那之后事情发生得很快。
I started to voice my unhappiness with the way the situation was handled, with the way we were treated, and that also kind of brought up all these feelings I'd been holding in about things I disagreed with, policy-wise, things I disagreed with, the way we even talked about other people of similar religious faith. It was sort of a cascading experience that just really snowballed really quickly from that point.
我开始表达我对处理这种情况的方式、我们被对待的方式的不满，这也引出了我一直压抑的关于我不同意的事情的所有感受，在政策方面，我不同意的事情，甚至是我们谈论其他具有相似宗教信仰的人的方式。这是一种连锁反应，从那时起迅速升级。
I understand that at one point, uh, you went to a movie, which is something that the church had actually recommended that you not do. Yeah, it was, you know, these, these rules about church attendance and things like that, they're never formalized, they weren't written down anywhere, but of course we had really deeply believed them. I had internalized them. And one morning I just decided I don't want to go to Sunday service. I want to hang out with a non-religious person.
我了解到在某个时候，呃，你去看了电影，这是教会实际上建议你不要做的事情。是的，你知道，这些关于教会出席率之类的规则，它们从未被正式化，它们没有写在任何地方，但当然我们已经深深地相信了它们。我已经内化了它们。有一天早上我只是决定我不想去参加周日礼拜。我想和非宗教人士待在一起。
I want to just go to a movie and have a bowl of popcorn. I'm 20 years old. And that felt like very small. I'm sure no one in the movie theater thought I was doing anything brave, but to me it was a first step towards reclaiming my autonomy and realizing that, you know, maybe it's okay to have the desire to go see a movie and to just follow that desire. I'm wondering how the church responded to your evolution. You told me in the past they had not looked kindly at people who stepped out of line.
我只想去看场电影，吃一桶爆米花。我20岁了。这感觉非常微小。我相信电影院里没有人认为我在做什么勇敢的事情，但对我来说，这是迈向收回自主权的第一步，并意识到，你知道，也许有去看电影的愿望并跟随那个愿望也没关系。我想知道教会对你的演变有何反应。你过去告诉我，他们对那些不守规矩的人并不友善。
Yeah. So they were not a fan of what I was doing. They were not a fan of the things I was saying. The way that that was communicated was in a couple of one-on-one meetings and then the people really closest to me trying to implore me to sort of step back, to change my behavior, to sort of come back into the fold. At that point, I felt that that had been so severed that it almost felt like I couldn't come back. It felt like I was living in a totally different reality now from these people and I couldn't sit in the same rooms that I was in before. So it started off with these conversations and then it very quickly escalated into
是的。所以他们不喜欢我在做的事情。他们不喜欢我在说的事情。沟通方式是几次一对一的会议，然后真正最亲近我的人试图恳求我退一步，改变我的行为，回到团体中。在那一点上，我觉得那种联系已经被切断得太深了，以至于感觉我几乎无法回去。感觉我现在生活在一个与这些人完全不同的现实中，我无法坐在我以前坐的房间里。所以它从这些谈话开始，然后很快升级为
formal excommunication, which is I had to move out of my apartment where I was living with another member of the church. I lost contact with my immediate family at the time. Thankfully, we've reconnected since then. And I lost connections with pretty much every single person that I knew, including people I would consider family at that point. Wow. Wow. That must have been extraordinarily destabilizing, Erica. It was really destabilizing and it was really, really painful. Some of these relationships have still not been repaired. I still feel them like open wounds of these people that I really cared for. What I try to remember is they believe that they're doing the right thing. They think that you have to cut someone out of the group in order to maintain the functioning
正式的逐出教会，这意味着我必须搬出我和另一位教会成员合住的公寓。当时我失去了与直系亲属的联系。谢天谢地，我们从那以后重新建立了联系。我失去了与我认识的几乎每一个人的联系，包括那些我当时认为是家人的人。哇。哇。那一定非常令人不安，埃里卡。那确实非常令人不安，而且非常非常痛苦。其中一些关系至今仍未修复。我仍然能感觉到它们像开放的伤口一样，那些我曾经真正关心的人。我试着记住的是，他们相信他们是在做正确的事情。他们认为你必须把某人从团体中剔除，以维持团体的运作，
of the group and also in order to teach that person a lesson that if we release you out into the world, you'll sort of learn the world is wrong and you'll want to come back in. So slowly but surely every person that I knew gave me a call and said, hey, you know, I'm sorry, but we can't talk anymore. At one time or another, we've all felt the painful disjunction Erika is talking about. A mismatch between how we feel on the inside and how we're expected to be on the outside. When we come back, the costs of being inauthentic and the benefits of being your true self. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Social life often calls on us to act in ways
同时也为了给那个人一个教训，即如果我们把你释放到世界上，你会学到世界是错误的，你会想要回来。所以慢慢地，我认识的每一个人都给我打了电话说，嘿，你知道，我很抱歉，但我们不能再说话了。在某个时候，我们都感受到了埃里卡所说的痛苦脱节。我们内心的感受与我们被期望表现出的外在形象之间的不匹配。当我们回来时，我们将探讨不真实的代价以及做回真实自我的好处。你正在收听《Hidden Brain》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这里是《Hidden Brain》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。社交生活经常要求我们以
that don't match up with what we feel or believe. What are the consequences of this mismatch and what do we gain when we bring our inner and outer selves into alignment. Erica Bailey is a social scientist at the University of California, Berkeley. She studies the psychology of authenticity. Erica, we just heard about how painful it was for you to feel that your inner self was not in accord with the community that surrounded you. Scholars in your field have found that your experience was not unique when the inner self is not in alignment with the outer self. This can produce feelings of stress and exhaustion. Yeah, so this feeling we refer to as inauthenticity. And inauthenticity has a couple of sources or variants. On the one hand, you can feel inauthentic because you don't know who you are. So
与我们感受或信仰不符的方式行事。这种不匹配的后果是什么？当我们使内在和外在的自我保持一致时，我们获得了什么？埃里卡·贝利是加州大学伯克利分校的社会科学家。她研究真实性的心理学。埃里卡，我们刚刚听到了你感觉到你的内在自我与周围社区不一致是多么痛苦。你所在领域的学者发现，当内在自我与外在自我不一致时，你的经历并非个例。这会产生压力和精疲力竭的感觉。是的，所以这种感觉我们称之为“不真实”。而不真实有几个来源或变体。一方面，你可能感到不真实，因为你不知道你是谁。所以
you feel like yourself is somewhere separate. You feel disconnected from that true self and it feels inaccessible almost to you. On the other hand, inauthenticity could also be, I know very well who I am and what I want to say in this moment, but for whatever reason, I'm choosing to deny that. I'm choosing to express myself in a way that's counter to that internal experience. And that sounds more like the experience you had with the church. Yeah, I knew very clearly or I felt at least that I knew who I was internally or I had some sense of inner self, but I was not able to access that
你觉得自我好像在某个独立的地方。你感到与那个真实的自我脱节，它对你来说几乎是不可触及的。另一方面，不真实也可能是，我非常清楚我是谁以及我此刻想说什么，但由于某种原因，我选择否认这一点。我选择以一种与那种内在体验相反的方式表达自己。这听起来更像你在教会的经历。是的，我非常清楚地知道，或者至少我觉得我知道我在内在是谁，或者我对内在自我有一些感觉，但我无法触及它
or bring that forward in the group. What do we know, not just in your individual case, but in general, about the effects of inauthenticity on our experience of stress and exhaustion. Inauthenticity is a really taxing psychological experience. It can make you feel anxious, it can make you feel depressed, and it really separates you from being able to make genuine connections with other people
或者在团体中将其展现出来。除了你的个人案例，我们对不真实对我们的压力和精疲力竭体验的影响有什么普遍的了解吗？不真实是一种非常沉重的心理体验。它会让你感到焦虑，让你感到沮丧，并且它确实阻碍了你与他人建立真正的联系，
because you're so concerned with how you're coming across and managing that impression that you're creating in the other person. One of the interesting dimensions of inauthenticity is that in the workplace we often sometimes feel like we cannot be the real us. Social scientists sometimes call this emotional labor. What is the idea of emotional labor, Erica? this emotional labor. What is the idea of emotional labor, Erica? When sociologists talk about emotional labor, what they're referring to as this act of managing your impressions or the way you're coming across in these professional environments where we usually have norms about how to behave, norms about how to express yourself, and these can even be formalized rules about the way you need to dress, the way you need to appear, and how you need to treat those people that you're interacting
因为你太关注你给人的印象，以及管理你在对方心中创造的那种印象。不真实的一个有趣维度是，在工作场所，我们有时觉得我们不能做真实的自己。社会科学家有时称之为“情绪劳动”。什么是情绪劳动的概念，埃里卡？这种情绪劳动。什么是情绪劳动的概念，埃里卡？当社会学家谈论情绪劳动时，他们指的是在这些专业环境中管理你的印象或你给人的方式的行为，我们通常有关于如何表现的规范，关于如何表达自己的规范，这些甚至可以是关于你需要如何着装、你需要如何出现以及你需要如何对待那些你正在互动的人的正式规则。
with. So that experience of having to manage how you're coming across at times when that is conflicting with your inner self requires some labor, where the emotional labor term comes from. It requires some effort on your part to sort of keep up appearances. One example that sociologists mention is the service with a smile. So customer service representatives have to appear cheery and open and agreeable to people that they're interacting with, even if they are having a bad day or they're tired or they're talking to. In her 1983 book, The Managed Heart, Commercialization of Human Feeling, the sociologist Arlie Hochschild said that emotional labor is something that is in a variety of different professions.
所以，在与你的内在自我冲突时，不得不管理你给人的方式的那种体验需要一些劳动，这就是“情绪劳动”一词的由来。这需要你付出一些努力来维持表象。社会学家提到的一个例子是“微笑服务”。所以客户服务代表必须对他们互动的人表现得愉快、开放和随和，即使他们度过了糟糕的一天，或者他们很累，或者他们正在交谈。在她1983年的书《被管理的心：人类情感的商业化》中，社会学家阿莉·霍克希尔德说，情绪劳动是存在于各种不同职业中的东西。
So daycare workers and nursing home attendants might need to suppress their feelings of frustration when the people they are caring for act up. You know, a bill collector might need to come across as unforgiving when he might actually be feeling bad for the person he is talking with. You know, cops might need to come across as tough when they are feeling scared. So basically the idea is that you're not just being hired
所以日托工作者和疗养院护理员可能需要在他们照顾的人胡闹时压抑他们的挫败感。你知道，收债员在可能实际上对与他交谈的人感到难过时，可能需要表现得冷酷无情。你知道，警察在感到害怕时可能需要表现得强硬。所以基本上这个想法是，你不仅仅是被雇佣
to do a job, but you're required to manage and produce feelings that you might not actually be feeling, which of course is another way of saying you're required to be inauthentic. Exactly. Or at times you're required to be inauthentic. As someone who worked in restaurants, sometimes you are having a great conversation with someone. You are smiling because you're having a good day, but that's not always the case. We've seen a lot post- post COVID of these videos of customer service
来做一份工作，而是你被要求管理和产生你可能实际上并没有感受到的情感，这当然是说你被要求不真实的另一种方式。正是如此。或者有时你被要求不真实。作为一个在餐馆工作过的人，有时你和某人谈话很愉快。你微笑是因为你度过了美好的一天，但这并不总是这样。我们在新冠疫情后看到了很多这些视频，关于客户服务
representatives, essential workers, airline attendants that are having to deal with people who are speaking to them in a way that's inappropriate or not respectful. And, you know, deep down, they must be hurting, they must be upset. But they have to maintain that air of professionalism, even under those high pressure situations. You know I was at a bar in Chicago a couple of days ago and there were these two men sitting at the bar who were having a debate with one another and the bartender was standing behind the bar and she had this you know this fixed smile on her face and I was wondering what was going
代表、必要工作者、航空公司乘务员不得不处理那些以不恰当或不尊重的方式与他们交谈的人。而且，你知道，在内心深处，他们一定很受伤，他们一定很沮丧。但他们必须保持那种专业精神，即使在那些高压情况下。你知道，几天前我在芝加哥的一家酒吧，有两个男人坐在吧台边争论，女调酒师站在吧台后面，她脸上带着那种，你知道，那种固定的微笑，我在想她在想什么，
through her head because these two guys were really going at it and they were just going on and on and on. And she kept this smile on her face and I couldn't help but think that she probably was rolling her eyes on the inside and smiling on the outside. She might have been rolling her eyes,
因为这两个家伙真的在争论，而且他们没完没了。她脸上一直保持着那种微笑，我不禁想到她内心可能在翻白眼，而外表却在微笑。她可能在翻白眼，
looking at the clock, pretending to wash some cups underneath the, you know, far down at the other end of the bar to stay away from them so she doesn't get dragged into it. Yeah. Yeah, you really see everything working in restaurants. I understand that early in your career,
看着时钟，假装在吧台远端的下面洗一些杯子，你知道，为了远离他们，这样她就不会被卷进去。是的。是的，你在餐馆里真的什么都能看到。我了解到在你职业生涯的早期，
you worked as a consultant at IBM, and in your first weeks, you got some training that showed you not just what the company expected of you in terms of the work you had to do, but also what they expected of you in terms of your emotions. Tell me a little bit about that, Erica. Like many companies, IBM has what we call newcomer socialization, which is where they try
你在IBM担任顾问，在最初的几周里，你接受了一些培训，这些培训不仅向你展示了公司在工作方面对你的期望，还展示了他们在情感方面对你的期望。告诉我一点关于那个的情况，埃里卡。像许多公司一样，IBM有所谓的新人社会化，这是他们尝试
and teach you about the organization's norms, the culture, help you understand, you know, the broader mission of the company. And as a consultant, that was particularly important because we would be going out to client site on behalf of IBM. So they wanted us to have a clear sense of that organizational identity and be able to bring that persona to our clients.
教导你关于组织的规范、文化，帮助你理解，你知道，公司更广泛的使命。作为一名顾问，这一点尤为重要，因为我们将代表IBM前往客户现场。所以他们希望我们对那种组织身份有清晰的认识，并能够将那种人格带给我们的客户。
So this came in the form of how we looked, looking professional, being on time. We even had everybody had the same ThinkPad computers. We had the same cell phones. We were really well branded as IBMers. At the same time, some of these, again, are just sort of internalized norms. So I'm a person that has visible tattoos,
所以这表现为我们的外表，看起来专业，准时。我们甚至每个人都有相同的ThinkPad电脑。我们有相同的手机。我们作为IBM员工的品牌形象非常好。与此同时，其中一些，再次，只是某种内化的规范。所以我是一个有可见纹身的人，
and I was so concerned of anyone seeing my tattoos because surely this is against IBM's policy. And I asked a HR person, they said, oh, we have no policy about tattoos. Feel free to show them as long as the client thinks it's fine. We think it's great. Yeah, so long as you're carrying your ThinkPad and you're on time, the tattoos don't matter.
我非常担心有人看到我的纹身，因为这肯定违反了IBM的政策。我问了一位人力资源人员，他们说，哦，我们没有关于纹身的政策。只要客户认为没问题，请随意展示它们。我们认为这很棒。是的，只要你带着你的ThinkPad并且准时，纹身并不重要。
Exactly. As long as your shirt is ironed, you can show your tattoo. But I am wondering in some ways, Erica, whether some of us feel the need to conceal parts of ourselves, and perhaps this is especially true if you're someone who is breaking a barrier to enter a profession. So a woman working on an oil rig or a man working as a nurse might have to go out of their way to conceal parts of themselves that might play into the stereotypes that others have of them. And again, this might be a prescription for inauthenticity.
正是如此。只要你的衬衫熨烫平整，你就可以展示你的纹身。但我很好奇，在某些方面，埃里卡，我们中是否有些人觉得需要隐藏自己的一部分，也许如果你是一个打破障碍进入某个职业的人，这一点尤其正确。所以一个在石油钻井平台上工作的女性或一个担任护士的男性可能不得不竭尽全力隐藏自己的一部分，这些部分可能会迎合他人对他们的刻板印象。同样，这可能是不真实的处方。
Absolutely, and I, you know, we're being lighthearted about it, but I don't want to ignore the fact that for some people, you know, their authentic self could bring significant interpersonal costs. It can be a life or death matter to express some identities that people have. So sometimes that is a really serious thing
绝对是，而且我，你知道，我们对此表现得轻松，但我不想忽视这样一个事实，即对于某些人来说，你知道，他们真实的自我可能会带来重大的个人代价。表达某些人拥有的身份可能是一个生死攸关的问题。所以有时那确实是一件非常严肃的事情，
that people manage where they keep parts of their personal self separate from their work self. At the same time, that's a really difficult psychological experience for that person. And what I usually tell people is that's the job of the manager to think about maybe how to create an environment that's more welcoming or open or accepting
人们在管理它，他们将个人自我的部分与工作自我分开。与此同时，这对那个人来说是一种非常困难的心理体验。我通常告诉人们的是，这是经理的工作，去思考如何创造一个更受欢迎、更开放或更接受的环境，
of different identities, different individuals who are coming into a space where they might look the same as everyone else, but they're carrying something internal that we can't all see. So, we've seen how emotional labor can come with feelings of stress and feelings of exhaustion, but there are other costs as well. When people are inauthentic, they seem to be at greater risk of engaging in unethical behavior that can also harm others.
接受不同的身份，不同的个体进入一个空间，他们可能看起来和每个人都一样，但他们携带了一些我们无法看到的内在东西。所以，我们已经看到了情绪劳动如何伴随着压力和精疲力竭的感觉，但还有其他代价。当人们不真实时，他们似乎更有可能从事可能伤害他人的不道德行为。
Can you tell me about this research, Erica? This research followed what I think is a real intuitive idea, which is we all have a personal and professional self. Most of us don't behave in the workplace identically to the way we behave at home. So you can think about these two circles of two selves. And the researchers thought about the way
你能告诉我关于这项研究吗，埃里卡？这项研究遵循了我认为是一个真正直观的想法，即我们每个人都有一个个人自我和一个专业自我。我们大多数人在工作场所的行为与我们在家里的行为并不完全相同。所以你可以把这两个自我的圆圈想成是这样。研究人员思考了我们看待
that we think of those disparate circles as integrated or segmented. So they're either overlapping, they're coherent, they make sense together, or they're really far apart. And what happens when those two identities are really far apart, when your work self is very different and segmented from your home self, is that you can pick and choose that, you know, at work, I can be unethical, immoral, I can lie, which is what the experimenters looked at, because it's not diagnostic of my real self,
那些截然不同的圆圈是整合的还是分割的方式。所以它们要么是重叠的，它们是连贯的，它们在一起是有意义的，要么它们相距甚远。当这两个身份相距甚远时，当你的工作自我与你的家庭自我非常不同且被分割时，会发生什么呢？那就是你可以挑选，你知道，在工作中，我可以不道德、不道德，我可以撒谎，这就是实验者所观察到的，因为这并不能诊断我真实的自我，
my core self, the person I am at home. And that separation allows people who see themselves as otherwise moral to engage in immoral behavior. I mean, at an extreme level, I can see somebody who's a mobster who basically says, you know, I can go out and kill someone as part of, you know, something that's happening in my quote unquote professional world, but I can come home and I can love my, you know, my partner and my children and I'm a good husband, I'm a good father, I'm a good person, even
我的核心自我，我在家里那个人的样子。这种分离允许那些认为自己是道德的人从事不道德的行为。我的意思是，在极端层面上，我可以想象一个黑帮分子，他基本上说，你知道，我可以出去杀人，作为，你知道，在我所谓的专业世界里发生的事情的一部分，但我可以回家，我可以爱我的，你知道，我的伴侣和我的孩子，我是一个好丈夫，我是一个好父亲，我是一个好人，即使
though I've done something terrible 20 minutes ago. Exactly. Or on the other hand, some people become so invested, and so their identity becomes such a part of their work identity that the only thing that matters to them are these work successes or achieving something at work or climbing the corporate ladder and sort of what happens, how they treat their friends, their family members, people outside of the workplace
我20分钟前做了一些可怕的事情。正是如此。或者另一方面，有些人变得如此投入，以至于他们的身份变成了他们工作身份的一部分，以至于对他们来说唯一重要的事情就是这些工作上的成功，或者在工作中取得成就，或者攀登企业阶梯，而发生的事情，他们如何对待他们的朋友、他们的家人、工作场所之外的人
are irrelevant to sort of where that source of self-esteem comes from. Some years ago, the comedian Ellen DeGeneres came under fire for creating a toxic work environment at her show. Ultimately, three producers were dismissed and Ellen DeGeneres apologized to her staff. You say that this story has something to say about the nature of authenticity. How so, Erica? Ellen DeGeneres, like many social figures, looms sort of large in people's minds. We all felt, or most people who watched her show
与那种自尊的来源无关。几年前，喜剧演员艾伦·德杰尼勒斯因在她的节目中创造了一个有毒的工作环境而受到抨击。最终，三名制片人被解雇，艾伦·德杰尼勒斯向她的员工道歉。你说这个故事对于真实性的本质有一些话要说。怎么说，埃里卡？艾伦·德杰尼勒斯，像许多社会人物一样，在人们心中占据了很大的位置。我们都觉得，或者大多数看她节目的人
felt like we knew her, or felt like we understand this person. She presented sort of this image of someone that's kind, someone that's very easygoing, lighthearted, and very authentic, while from these reports, what we've heard is that she could be very different to the people that were working with her directly and create an environment where they did not feel
觉得我们认识她，或者觉得我们了解这个人。她呈现出一种善良、非常随和、轻松、非常真实的形象，而从这些报道中，我们听到的是，她对直接与她一起工作的人可能非常不同，并创造了一个环境，让他们觉得
that she was really accepting and open the way she was presenting herself to the world. Let's talk a moment about some of the benefits of authenticity. What are the effects of authenticity on our well-being and self-esteem, Erica? Authenticity is linked to greater subjective wellbeing. So this is feeling like you're satisfied with your life
她并不像她向世界展示的那样真正接受和开放。让我们谈谈真实性的一些好处。真实性对我们的幸福感和自尊有什么影响，埃里卡？真实性与更高的主观幸福感有关。所以这感觉就像你对你的生活感到满意，
and also feeling positive affect or happiness and good feelings. So authenticity is really predictive of having that view of your life, that things are going well. It's also related to feeling like you have meaning in your life and having better satisfaction with your relationships.
同时也感到积极的情感或快乐和良好的感觉。所以真实性确实是拥有那种生活观的预测指标，即事情进展顺利。它也与感觉你的生活有意义以及与你的关系有更好的满意度有关。
And in some of my work, we've also tried to extend that into the workplace to find how authenticity relates to the way you engage with your work tasks. So feeling authentic at work or feeling like you can be your authentic self at work also helps you focus on the tasks at hand, because you're not taking up so much mental space or engaging in that emotional labor about how you're coming across or how is everyone thinking of me in this meeting. You can really just be present and engaged with your work tasks as they come. So one domain where people face an ever-present tension about whether to be authentic is on
在我的一些工作中，我们也试图将其扩展到工作场所，以发现真实性如何与你参与工作任务的方式相关联。所以，在工作中感到真实，或者觉得你可以在工作中做真实的自己，也有助于你专注于手头的任务，因为你没有占用太多的心理空间，或者从事那种关于你给人的方式，或者每个人在这次会议上怎么看我的情绪劳动。你可以真正地活在当下，并专注于你的工作任务。所以，人们面临关于是否要真实的持续紧张的一个领域是
social media. Do you present your true self to the world or do you present an idealized picture of your life to the world? You ran a study looking at the well-being of more than 10,000 people who were either more or less authentic on Facebook. Can you describe the study and what you found? Yeah, I would be happy to. So this was co-first authored work with Sandra Matz at Columbia Business School.
社交媒体。你是向世界展示真实的自己，还是向世界展示你生活的理想化画面？你进行了一项研究，观察了10,000多名在Facebook上或多或少真实的人的幸福感。你能描述一下这项研究以及你的发现吗？是的，我很乐意。所以这是与哥伦比亚商学院的桑德拉·马茨共同完成的工作。
And we were interested not just in whether social media is good or bad for well-being, we were really interested in for whom is social media good or bad in terms of their well-being and are there decisions that people are making with how they engage with these tools that differentially impact how that tool use relates to themselves or their view of themselves. So what we looked at is 10,000 over 10,000 Facebook users we compared their self-rated personality so what we call their self view with the way they express themselves on Facebook. And what we found is sort of that distance between the way you see yourself
我们感兴趣的不仅仅是社交媒体对幸福感是好是坏，我们真正感兴趣的是，对于谁来说，社交媒体在幸福感方面是好是坏，以及人们在如何使用这些工具时所做的决定是否会差异化地影响该工具的使用如何与他们自己或他们对自己的看法相关联。所以我们观察的是10,000多名Facebook用户，我们比较了他们的自我评价人格，也就是我们所说的他们的自我观，与他们在Facebook上表达自己的方式。我们发现的是，你对自己的看法
and the way you were expressing yourself on social media was correlated with subjective well-being, such that if you're closer in terms of your self-view and your online persona, you had higher well-being. So it's so striking, Erika, because I think many of us, you know, notice that when you look at social media feeds, especially, you know, Facebook and Instagram, we're often confronted by the fact that people are sharing very positive images of their life, right? So people are sharing the best moments, the happiest moments, the most glowing moments of their lives.
与你在社交媒体上表达自己的方式之间的那种距离与主观幸福感相关，即如果你在自我观和在线人格方面更接近，你的幸福感就更高。所以这太惊人了，埃里卡，因为我认为我们许多人，你知道，注意到当你查看社交媒体动态时，特别是，你知道，Facebook和Instagram，我们经常面对这样一个事实，即人们正在分享他们生活的非常积极的形象，对吧？所以人们正在分享他们生活中最美好的时刻、最快乐的时刻、最光辉的时刻。
And we sometimes contrast that with, you know, the messiness of our own lives. And we say, you know, other people are living perfect lives and I'm not living a perfect life. But I think what you're getting at is actually something really interesting, which is that this disjuncture doesn't just affect me looking at somebody else's social media feed and saying, that person has a perfect life and I don't. You're saying that if that person is expressing they have a perfect life, but in fact they don't, it actually is bad for them. Exactly. You know, there's this phenomenon where people will gaze upon their own social media page and sort of like look at this version of
而我们有时会将此与，你知道，我们自己生活的混乱进行对比。我们说，你知道，其他人过着完美的生活，而我没有过着完美的生活。但我认为你所指出的实际上是非常有趣的事情，那就是这种脱节不仅仅影响我看着别人的社交媒体动态并说，那个人有完美的生活，而我没有。你说的是，如果那个人表达他们有完美的生活，但事实上他们没有，这对他们来说实际上是有害的。正是如此。你知道，有一种现象，人们会凝视他们自己的社交媒体页面，有点像看着这个版本的
their life they've created and that can be a really dissonant experience if that's really different than your day-to-day or your emotional experience. Feeling phony extracts a high emotional and psychological cost. Acting in tune with our inner core grants us a sense of meaning and satisfaction. When we come back, the steps we can take to get in touch with our true selves. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam.
他们创造的生活，如果这与你的日常或情感体验真的不同，那可能是一种非常不和谐的体验。感到虚伪会付出高昂的情感和心理代价。以与我们内在核心一致的方式行事会赋予我们一种意义感和满足感。当我们回来时，我们将探讨我们可以采取的步骤来接触我们真实的自我。你正在收听《Hidden Brain》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这里是《Hidden Brain》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。
In one sense, we are always ourselves. Even when we are pretending to feel something we don't feel, or say something we don't believe, the things we feel and say are also us. Our desire to pretend to be someone we are not is also who we are. But social scientist Erika Bailey says, there are moments we all feel fully and truly ourselves. We feel real, genuine, and authentic. She and others have studied how we can make those moments more frequent. Erika, can you paint me a picture of a time in your own life where you felt truly authentic? What you're describing is this experience of state authenticity or those moments where you feel really aligned and connected with your core self.
从某种意义上说，我们始终是我们自己。即使当我们假装感受不到某种情绪，或者说出违心的话时，我们所感受和表达的一切也依然是我们的一部分。我们想要假装成另一个人的渴望，同样也是我们自身的一部分。但社会科学家埃里卡·贝利（Erika Bailey）表示，我们每个人都有完全真实地感受到自我的时刻。我们会感到真实、纯粹且忠于自我。她和其他研究人员一直在研究如何让这些时刻变得更加频繁。埃里卡，你能描述一下你生活中感到真正忠于自我的时刻吗？你所描述的正是这种“状态真实感”（state authenticity），即那些让你感到与核心自我真正契合与连接的时刻。
One moment that is really small from my own life but that I go back to often was a time in high school where we were driving around with my friends in the car. It was a sunny day. The windows were down, music was playing and we were all singing at the top of our lungs. And that moment felt so authentic because, you know, I was so happy.
我生活中有一个非常微小但却经常回味的时刻，那是在高中时期，我和朋友们开车兜风。那天阳光明媚，车窗摇下，音乐播放着，我们都在大声歌唱。那一刻我感到非常真实，因为，你知道，我当时真的太快乐了。
You know, being a kid, you feel free for the first time when you're in a car, There's no adults around you. And I was experiencing that connection with my friends over this music and song and really feeling like this is where I belong in this moment. Why do you think it's useful for all of us to remember moments like this, Erica? Moments like this can help clue us into how authenticity is so fun and also sort of complicated, right? So I ask a lot of people to tell me about these moments in their lives, and people will mention things like the birth of a child. And it's a moment where you feel really
你知道，作为孩子，当你坐在车里时，你会第一次感到自由，周围没有大人。我当时正通过音乐和歌声体验着与朋友们的这种连接，并真切地感觉到：在这一刻，我属于这里。埃里卡，你认为为什么记住这样的时刻对我们所有人都有益呢？像这样的时刻可以帮助我们意识到，真实感既有趣又有些复杂，对吧？所以我经常请人们告诉我他们生活中这些时刻，人们会提到像孩子出生这样的事情。那是一个让你感到非常
authentic, really connected, but of course your identity has just changed dramatically. You know, you've now got a new identity, being a father, being a mother, being a parent, and yet you still feel very authentic, like this is now what my life is, this was how it was supposed to be. And that helps clue us into how this true self, this inner self can constantly evolve and change.
真实、非常有连接感的时刻，但当然，你的身份也刚刚发生了巨大的变化。你知道，你现在有了一个新的身份，成为了一名父亲、母亲或家长，但你仍然感到非常真实，觉得这就是我现在的生活，这就是它本该有的样子。这有助于我们理解这种真实的自我、这种内在的自我可以如何不断地演变和改变。
You know, I'm wondering if this might be one of the reasons people turn to alcohol and other drugs. So know, so a drink might actually loosen our inhibition so we feel like we can dance like no one is watching, but it might also be that the drink gives us permission to loosen our inhibitions to feel like we can truly be ourselves. One of my advisors, Adam Golinski, has this work about disinhibition and how things like being anonymous online, being able to pass a message anonymously to someone else or having a drink can help us feel free from these social constraints to express how we really feel. Unfortunately, on social media, sometimes that comes across really negatively.
你知道，我在想这是否是人们转向酒精和其他药物的原因之一。所以，一杯酒可能真的会放松我们的抑制，让我们觉得可以像没人看着一样跳舞，但也可能这杯酒给了我们许可，去放松抑制，去感觉我们可以真正做回自己。我的导师之一亚当·戈林斯基（Adam Golinski）有关于“去抑制”（disinhibition）的研究，探讨了诸如在网上匿名、能够匿名给别人发信息或喝上一杯酒，如何能帮助我们摆脱这些社会约束，从而表达我们真实的感受。不幸的是，在社交媒体上，有时这会产生非常负面的影响。
But sometimes having that you know, that moment with someone else where you're sharing a glass of wine and you feel like, oh, yeah, maybe these concerns I had about how this conversation would go were in my head and I can sort of relax into the moment and be really present with this person that I'm talking to. Now, hidden brain listeners are a very cerebral group of people.
但有时，当你与某人分享一杯红酒，感觉“哦，是的，也许我之前对这次谈话会如何进行的担忧只是我自己的胡思乱想，我可以放松下来，真正专注于与我交谈的这个人”时，那种时刻也是有的。现在，“隐藏大脑”（Hidden Brain）的听众是一群非常理性的群体。
We might think that the best way to feel authentic is to reflect and introspect about what it means to be authentic. You say this might not be the best path. What's wrong with thinking our way to authenticity and what is a better path? Thinking our way into authenticity or trying to maybe just look inwards to find that core central self that's really going to make us happy is challenging because social psychologists would say, if you look inwards, there's not really anything there. What you have is almost a mess of data.
我们可能认为，感受真实感的最好方法是反思和内省，思考“真实”意味着什么。你说这可能不是最好的途径。通过思考来达到真实感有什么问题？更好的途径是什么？试图通过思考来达到真实感，或者仅仅向内看去寻找那个能让我们快乐的核心自我，是充满挑战的，因为社会心理学家会说，如果你向内看，其实什么都没有。你所拥有的几乎是一团混乱的数据。
You have all these impulses, you have all these decisions that you've made, some of which you're proud of, some of which you're not, some of which you were proud of in the moment and now you've come to regret. And so turning inwards, you are left to try and sort out or try to understand sometimes really conflicting bits of data about who you are. And so what I often recommend to people is instead of focusing too much internally, where things like self-criticism or self-doubt or social comparison can come into play, sometimes it helps to look outwardly and think about those situations
你拥有所有这些冲动，拥有所有你做过的决定，其中一些你引以为豪，一些则不然，还有一些是你当时引以为豪但现在却感到后悔的。因此，向内看时，你只能试图整理或理解关于“你是谁”的、有时非常矛盾的数据片段。所以我经常建议人们，与其过度关注内心——那些自我批评、自我怀疑或社会比较可能会产生影响的地方——有时向外看，思考那些你真正感到真实的处境，会更有帮助，它们是你了解自己是谁的线索。
where you really felt authentic as clues for who you are. You can also think about trying on different identities. Like, maybe I don't know if I like playing pickleball, for example, that's my new identity. And so you have to try it and you can feel in that moment, pay attention to how that moment makes you feel. Does it make you feel alive? Does it make you feel connected with who you are? And if it doesn't, no harm, no foul. Now you've learned something important from that situation.
你也可以考虑尝试不同的身份。比如，我不知道我是否喜欢打匹克球，举个例子，这是我的新身份。所以你必须去尝试，在那个时刻，注意这种体验让你感觉如何。它让你感到充满活力吗？它让你感到与真实的自我有连接吗？如果不是，也没关系，没有损失。现在你从那种情境中学到了一些重要的东西。
So in other words, when you think back to that moment in the car when you were singing with your friends, it wasn't just a feeling of being authentic. What you're saying, it's almost diagnostic. It was actually telling you something about yourself. Exactly. It's like a way to learn more about yourself, become more aware of who you are through reflecting on these experiences or through going out and having those experiences and bringing back self-knowledge into that internal experience. I understand, Erica, that you had an experience along these lines when you first started teaching.
换句话说，当你回想起在车里和朋友们唱歌的那一刻，那不仅仅是一种真实的感觉。你的意思是，它几乎是诊断性的。它实际上是在告诉你关于你自己的某些信息。没错。这就像是一种了解更多关于自己的方式，通过反思这些经历，或者通过走出去获得这些体验，并将自我知识带回那种内在体验中，从而变得更加了解自己。埃里卡，我听说你刚开始教书时也有过类似的经历。
Tell me what your first day in class was like. The first day of class, my teaching assistant wasn't able to be there. So sort of my lifeline, my comfort person was not there. I just had like a binder with all my notes and sweaty palms, and I felt very inadequate to be the one standing in front of the room. But what I did in the moment was that sort of fake it till you make it where I stood on my two feet, said good morning to the class and thought about what value I could provide for them in the moment. So even though I was incredibly nervous, even though I was sweating, even though my voice was probably shaking at the time, I tried to approach them with sincerity, with openness, and allowed
告诉我你第一天上课是什么样的。第一天上课时，我的助教没能到场。所以，我那根“救命稻草”、那个能给我安慰的人不在了。我手里只有一本装满笔记的活页夹，手心冒汗，我觉得自己站在教室前面显得非常不称职。但在那一刻，我所做的是那种“假装直到你成功”（fake it till you make it）的做法，我站稳脚跟，对班级说了声早上好，并思考在那一刻我能为他们提供什么价值。所以，尽管我非常紧张，尽管我在出汗，尽管我的声音当时可能在颤抖，但我试着以真诚、开放的态度去面对他们，并允许
that experience to maybe feel uncomfortable, but approach it in a way that, you know, I am competent and I can do this. And it's only after, you know, that first lecture, left first lecture and a half where I realized, actually, I really like this. This is really engaging. This is really engaging. This is really interesting. And they brought me amazing research ideas and examples that I can bring back into my other identity as a researcher. And in some ways, it goes back to what you were saying
那种体验可能带来的不适感，但以一种“我是胜任的，我可以做到”的方式去应对。直到那节课结束，或者说第一节半课结束后，我才意识到：其实，我真的很喜欢这样。这真的很吸引人。这真的很吸引人。这真的很有趣。他们带给我了很棒的研究想法和案例，我可以把这些带回我作为研究者的另一个身份中。在某种程度上，这回到了你刚才所说的
a second earlier, which is that when you recognize that you're in the flow, you're feeling authentic, it actually tells you something important about yourself. Absolutely. I learned that teaching is a huge part of my identity. It's something I find really rewarding and really valuable, and I appreciate and look forward to that time in the classroom with my students. One of the things you said a second ago just struck me, Erica, which is that one way we
那一秒钟前的话，即当你意识到自己处于“心流”状态，感到真实时，它实际上是在告诉你关于你自己的重要信息。绝对是这样。我了解到教学是我身份中非常重要的一部分。我发现这非常有意义且非常有价值，我很珍惜并期待与学生们在教室里的时光。埃里卡，你刚才说的一件事让我印象深刻，那就是我们
can feel more authentic is to remind ourselves about our core values. Tell me about the research carried out by another former guest of Hidden Brain, the psychologist Sheena Iyengar. Well, Sheena Iyengar is my advisor, so I got to spend a lot of time with her. And together with Paul Ingram, who's another professor at Columbia, they walked students through this exercise, which is a values exercise. And what this helps you do is iterate through a set of values until you feel like you've identified sort of your core values and you understand like, what's the most important
感到更真实的一种方式是提醒自己关注核心价值观。请告诉我另一位“隐藏大脑”的前嘉宾、心理学家希娜·艾扬格（Sheena Iyengar）所进行的研究。嗯，希娜·艾扬格是我的导师，所以我有很多时间和她在一起。她和哥伦比亚大学的另一位教授保罗·英格拉姆（Paul Ingram）一起，引导学生完成这个练习，这是一个价值观练习。这能帮助你反复筛选一系列价值观，直到你觉得已经确定了自己的核心价值观，并且理解了什么是对你最重要的
value to you? What's your what's the most important value to you, what's your second and third most important value. What they found is that having students remind themselves of these values before giving a presentation led them to come across as more authentic to the audience. It was that ability to remember the core values that one has to remember that, you know, I'm not just here to give a meeting, I'm here to maybe help someone achieve something with their business. I'm maybe here to help motivate my employees to take the next step or to take that risk. And reminding themselves of those values actually helped those speeches seem more
价值观，什么是你第二和第三重要的价值观。他们发现，让学生在做演讲前提醒自己这些价值观，会使他们在听众面前显得更真实。正是那种记住自己核心价值观的能力，记住“我不仅仅是为了开会而来，我可能是为了帮助某人实现他们的商业目标而来。我可能是为了激励我的员工迈出下一步或承担风险而来”。提醒自己这些价值观，实际上帮助那些演讲在听众看来显得更加
authentic to the audience. Why do you think it is that reminding ourselves of our core values would help us come across to others as more authentic, Erica. One thing I've found in a couple of studies is sometimes we are stuck really up here in our heads and we forget that we sort of need to bring people into our backstage. We need to explain ourselves more than we think we do. We have all these internal motivations and feelings and evaluations that are going on behind the scenes and we think they're so perceptible to those around us but of course they're not, you know, they're
真实。埃里卡，你认为为什么提醒自己关注核心价值观会帮助我们在他人眼中显得更真实？我在几项研究中发现，有时我们太困在自己的头脑里了，忘记了我们需要把人们带入我们的“后台”。我们需要比自己想象中更多地解释自己。我们背后有着各种内在的动机、感受和评估，我们认为周围的人都能察觉到，但当然他们察觉不到，你知道，它们
locked up inside our minds and it can help to identify your values, your motives, why you're doing the things you're doing and to articulate those to other people. It helps them make sense of what they're seeing in terms of, oh, that's how they really feel behind the scenes. Erika, researchers have found that one way to generate a sense of authenticity is to engage in self-compassion.
锁在我们的脑海里。识别你的价值观、动机以及你做这些事情的原因，并向他人表达出来，是有帮助的。这能帮助他们理解他们所看到的东西，即“哦，原来他们在幕后是这样想的”。埃里卡，研究人员发现，产生真实感的一种方式是进行自我同情。
Can you tell me about this work and why self-compassion might be connected to feeling authentic? So this paper started with this question that a lot of authenticity researchers have, which is we sort of all agreed that authenticity is a good thing, but how do we get there? What's the steps that we need to take to experience more authenticity in our lives? And what they theorize is that this idea of self-compassion can help people feel more authentic. So self-compassion is having kindness towards yourself. It's also about recognizing that we're all human and part of being human is being imperfect and making mistakes and having the ability to reflect on those mistakes with
你能告诉我这项研究，以及为什么自我同情可能与感到真实有关吗？这篇论文始于许多真实感研究人员都有的一个问题，即我们都同意真实感是一件好事，但我们该如何达到呢？我们需要采取什么步骤才能在生活中体验到更多的真实感？他们的理论是，这种“自我同情”的理念可以帮助人们感到更真实。自我同情就是对自己怀有善意。它也关乎认识到我们都是人类，而作为人类的一部分，就是不完美、会犯错，并有能力以
sort of composure and awareness with acceptance. And what they found is that self-compassion, people who have higher traits, self-compassion experience greater trait authenticity, but also experimentally inducing self-compassion or having people engage in reflection exercises with more or less compassion predicted how authentic they were in that moment. And part of why that happens, which I love from this paper is it's associated with an increased optimism. So when we feel like we can approach our mistakes with kindness and with acceptance, we also feel like maybe I can do that tomorrow. And maybe if I make a mistake tomorrow, I can have the same mindset of kindness towards myself and the belief in future growth. And that
某种沉着和觉知，带着接纳去反思这些错误。他们发现，自我同情程度较高的人，其特质真实感也更高；而且，通过实验诱导自我同情，或者让人们进行或多或少的同情反思练习，可以预测他们在那一刻的真实感。这之所以会发生，部分原因（我非常喜欢这篇论文中的这一点）是它与乐观情绪的增加有关。所以，当我们觉得可以用善意和接纳来面对错误时，我们也觉得也许明天我可以做得更好。也许如果明天我犯了错，我也可以对自己保持同样的善意心态，并相信未来的成长。而这
can help me feel authentic in these moments even when reflecting on something that in hindsight we wish we would have done differently. You know, I'm also struck by the fact that when we try and identify our authentic self, you know, and we look inward we're obviously going to see things that are virtues, but we're also going to see things that are flaws and in some, being able to see ourselves authentically means to see the whole us, the good side and the bad side. And perhaps this is where self-compassion comes in, because as you start to see the flaws in yourself,
可以帮助我在这些时刻感到真实，即使是在反思那些事后希望自己能做得不同的事情时。你知道，我也被这样一个事实所触动：当我们试图确定真实的自我时，当我们向内看时，我们显然会看到美德，但也会看到缺陷。在某种程度上，能够真实地看待自己意味着看到完整的我们，好的一面和坏的一面。也许这就是自我同情发挥作用的地方，因为当你开始看到自己的缺陷时，
it might help to look at them with a little self-compassion. Exactly, it can even help you recognize that those are parts of who you are and think about ways to make progress towards them instead of using those aspects as a way to punish yourself or to feel badly about what you could have done or how you should be. ["Sweet Dreams"]
用一点自我同情来看待它们可能会有所帮助。没错，它甚至可以帮助你认识到那些也是你的一部分，并思考如何朝着它们做出改进，而不是利用这些方面来惩罚自己，或者对你本可以做到的事情或你应该成为的样子感到难过。["Sweet Dreams"]
Erika, I understand that there are challenging parts of your own mental makeup that you strive to handle with self-compassion. Can you give me an example? One example from my own life is I struggle with anxiety. It's something that was absolutely exacerbated with grad school and the pandemic and the many historical experiences that we're all living through. Part of what has helped me with recognizing I have anxiety is obviously being in therapy, but coming to understand where those anxious
埃里卡，我了解到你自己的心理构成中也有一些具有挑战性的部分，你努力以自我同情来处理。你能给我举个例子吗？我生活中的一个例子是我在与焦虑作斗争。这在研究生院、疫情以及我们所有人正在经历的许多历史性事件中绝对被加剧了。认识到我有焦虑症，部分帮助我的是接受治疗，但了解那些焦虑
thoughts come from has helped me have compassion for that side of myself. So when I'm ruminating over these experiences or having nightmares about how my first day of class is going to go, I can recognize that that's my body's way of trying to prepare me for those situations, trying to walk through the worst case scenario so that when it happens that I won't be so surprised. And of course, that's really not effective and I never feel prepared for those experiences. But recognizing the source of that and where it comes from has helped me approach that side of myself with more kindness and acceptance and has even sort of lessened its impact on my daily life. In other words, your mind is functioning like a smoke alarm that might be overly sensitive
想法的来源，帮助我对自己的那一面产生了同情。所以，当我反复思考这些经历，或者做关于第一天上课会如何进行的噩梦时，我可以认识到这是我的身体试图为这些情况做准备的方式，试图预演最坏的情况，这样当它发生时，我就不会那么惊讶。当然，这其实并不有效，我也从未觉得为这些经历做好了准备。但认识到它的来源和起因，帮助我以更多的善意和接纳来对待自己的那一面，甚至减轻了它对我日常生活的影响。换句话说，你的大脑就像一个可能过于敏感的烟雾报警器，
and it's going off and it's distracting and unpleasant, but it's not trying to be distracting or unpleasant. It's actually trying to help you. It's just, it's set, its threshold is set maybe slightly lower than it needs to be set. Exactly. One example is I get anxious when I first wake up in the morning and I'll feel really anxious when I'm in my kitchen making my coffee and what I sort of tell my body is like, I know that you feel like there's a tiger in the room, but there's not a tiger in the room. I'm just making my coffee and we're going to get through this coffee and then we're
它响了，虽然令人分心且不愉快，但它并不是故意要令人分心或不愉快。它实际上是在试图帮助你。只是，它的阈值可能设置得比实际需要稍微低了一点。没错。一个例子是，我每天早上刚醒来时会感到焦虑，在厨房煮咖啡时会感到非常焦虑，我告诉我的身体的是：“我知道你觉得房间里有一只老虎，但房间里并没有老虎。我只是在煮咖啡，我们会度过这段煮咖啡的时间，然后我们
going to approach our day with some calm and just kind of take it one step at a time. I want to contrast what you just said with I think what we often do, Erica, which is we have these feelings, we are anxious and we try and push the anxiety away and say, you know, why am I feeling anxious? And now you're not just anxious about whatever is happening in your day, you're anxious about being anxious, and then it becomes this vicious cycle. And I think what you're pointing to in some ways is that by sitting with the unpleasant emotion, and in fact welcoming it into the kitchen and basically saying I recognize why you're here, I recognize that you're trying to help me, it might not actually be helpful in the moment but I recognize
会带着平静的心情开始我们的一天，一步一步来。”埃里卡，我想把你刚才说的与我们经常做的事情进行对比，那就是我们有了这些感受，我们感到焦虑，然后我们试图把焦虑推开，说：“为什么我会感到焦虑？”现在你不仅对当天发生的任何事情感到焦虑，你还对“感到焦虑”这件事本身感到焦虑，然后这就变成了一个恶性循环。我认为你指出的在某种程度上是，通过与这种不愉快的情绪共处，事实上是欢迎它进入厨房，基本上说“我认识到你为什么在这里，我认识到你是在试图帮助我”，虽然它在当下可能并不真的有帮助，但我认识到
that your intentions are in the right place in some ways that lowers the the temperature in the room, it lowers the intensity of the anxiety. Absolutely and recognizing where that comes from and sort of where its bases are irrational can help me take it less seriously almost. That's part of where the idea that there's a tiger in the room makes me feel better. My body's having a really strong reaction that's sort of divorced from reality. And to the extent I can maybe poke fun at it or lessen its impact, I can almost embrace it and it feels less serious, it feels less all-consuming,
你的初衷是好的，在某种程度上这降低了房间里的温度，降低了焦虑的强度。绝对是这样，认识到它来自哪里，以及它的基础在某种程度上是不合理的，可以帮助我几乎不再那么认真地对待它。这就是为什么“房间里有老虎”这个想法让我感觉更好的部分原因。我的身体正在产生一种与现实脱节的强烈反应。只要我能拿它开开玩笑，或者减轻它的影响，我几乎可以拥抱它，它感觉就不那么严重了，感觉就不那么令人窒息了，
and it's still a part of myself, but it's one I can approach with more grace. You know, I often find, Erika, that when I talk with other people, my thoughts become clearer to myself. When I'm describing a problem that I'm having to someone else, all of a sudden I can see and understand the problem
它仍然是我自己的一部分，但我可以用更多的优雅来对待它。你知道，埃里卡，我经常发现，当我与他人交谈时，我的想法会变得更清晰。当我向别人描述我遇到的问题时，突然之间，我能比仅仅让它在自己脑海里转来转去时
much more clearly than if I just have it, you know, going round and round in my own head. Is it possible that talking to others in some ways can help us get in touch with what's happening inside ourselves and can be an engine of feeling more authentic? People often talk about conversations, especially with friends or close others, as a way to feel more authentic or moments where they really felt like themselves. Part of why that happens, I think, is people give you the space to explore those feelings, to talk about them in more detail, and they'll often ask questions or have you look at
更清晰地看到和理解这个问题。有没有可能，与他人交谈在某种程度上可以帮助我们触及内心正在发生的事情，并成为感受更真实的引擎？人们经常谈论对话，特别是与朋友或亲近的人的对话，作为一种感到更真实的方式，或者作为他们真正感到自我的时刻。我认为这之所以发生，部分原因是人们给了你探索这些感受的空间，让你更详细地谈论它们，他们通常会提出问题，或者让你从一个新的角度来看待
that problem from a new angle. With respect to anxiety, you know, when I talk to other people who have anxieties and they tell me the things they're anxious about, it seems like, why would I be anxious about that? And having that reaction to their anxiety makes me realize, oh my anxiety is also probably a little silly, like this is probably an irrational fear that I have and it almost helps you look at your own anxiety or your own troubles in a different way. In our companion story on Hidden Brain Plus, we will look at a paradox. As we have discussed many times on the show, we are a deeply social species.
那个问题。关于焦虑，你知道，当我与其他人交谈，他们也有焦虑，他们告诉我他们焦虑的事情时，看起来就像是：“我为什么要为那个感到焦虑？”对他们的焦虑产生这种反应，让我意识到，哦，我的焦虑可能也有一点傻，这可能是我的一种非理性恐惧，它几乎能帮助你以不同的方式看待你自己的焦虑或麻烦。在我们在“隐藏大脑Plus”（Hidden Brain Plus）上的配套故事中，我们将探讨一个悖论。正如我们在节目中多次讨论的那样，我们是一个深度社会化的物种。
All of us, in one way or another, rely on the kindness of strangers. Other people's opinions of us not only matter, they help constitute how we see ourselves. How do we square the imperative of being authentic, of marching to our own inner drummer, with the fact that other people play a large role in shaping how we feel about ourselves? How can we both care about other people's views and not care about other people's views at the same time? If you're a subscriber to Hidden Brain Plus, that episode should be available in your feed right now.
我们所有人，以这样或那样的方式，都依赖于陌生人的善意。别人对我们的看法不仅重要，而且有助于构成我们如何看待自己。我们如何将“保持真实”、跟随自己内心节奏的必要性，与“他人对我们如何看待自己起着重要作用”这一事实相协调？我们如何才能既关心他人的观点，同时又不关心他人的观点？如果你是“隐藏大脑Plus”的订阅者，该剧集现在应该可以在你的订阅源中看到了。
It's titled, The Us in Authenticity. If you're not yet a subscriber, you can sign up at apple.co. slash hidden brain. If you're using an Android device, you can sign up at support.hiddenbrain.org via our Patreon membership page. Erica Bailey is a social scientist at the Haas School of Business at the University of California, Berkeley. Erica Bailey, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you so much for having me, Shankar. MUSIC MUSIC
它的标题是《真实感中的“我们”》（The Us in Authenticity）。如果你还不是订阅者，可以在 apple.co/hiddenbrain 注册。如果你使用的是安卓设备，可以通过我们的 Patreon 会员页面在 support.hiddenbrain.org 注册。埃里卡·贝利是加州大学伯克利分校哈斯商学院的社会科学家。埃里卡·贝利，非常感谢你今天参加“隐藏大脑”。非常感谢你的邀请，尚卡尔。音乐 音乐
Do you have follow-up questions about authenticity for Erika Bailey? If you'd be comfortable sharing your question with a Hidden Brain audience, please record a voice memo on your phone and email it to us at ideas at hiddenbrain.org. That email address again is ideas at hiddenbrain.org. Use the subject line, authenticity. HiddenBrain is produced by HiddenBrain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quirell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick and Nick Woodbury.
你对埃里卡·贝利关于真实感的问题还有后续吗？如果你愿意与“隐藏大脑”的听众分享你的问题，请在手机上录制一段语音备忘录，并发送电子邮件至 ideas@hiddenbrain.org。再次重复那个邮箱地址：ideas@hiddenbrain.org。请使用主题行：authenticity。“隐藏大脑”由“隐藏大脑媒体”（Hidden Brain Media）制作。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲-保罗（Annie Murphy-Paul）、克里斯汀·王（Kristen Wong）、劳拉·奎雷尔（Laura Quirell）、瑞安·卡茨（Ryan Katz）、奥特姆·巴恩斯（Autumn Barnes）、安德鲁·查德威克（Andrew Chadwick）和尼克·伍德伯里（Nick Woodbury）。
Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brainins executive editor. Next week in our Wellness 2.0 series, curve balls and catastrophes. We look at the traits of people who cope extraordinarily well in moments of crisis. He says, I'm taking your vitals right now and you're completely calm. Like your blood pressure's fine, your arousal's fine, your heart rate is normal.
塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）是我们的执行制片人。我是“隐藏大脑”的执行编辑。下周在我们的“健康2.0”系列中，我们将探讨“曲线球与灾难”。我们来看看那些在危机时刻应对得格外好的人的特质。他说：“我正在测量你的生命体征，你完全冷静。你的血压正常，唤醒水平正常，心率正常。”
Like, how is that possible? And we heard that in her voice, the calmness in her voice, which is what was needed at that moment in time. That's next week in our Wellness 2.0 series. I hope you'll join us. Happy New Year from all of us at Hidden Brain. We look forward to bringing you lots of new ideas about human behavior this coming year.
“这怎么可能？”我们在她的声音中听到了这一点，她声音中的冷静，正是那一刻所需要的。这就是下周我们“健康2.0”系列的内容。希望你能加入我们。祝大家新年快乐，来自“隐藏大脑”全体成员。我们期待在未来的一年里为您带来更多关于人类行为的新想法。
I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆（Shankar Vedantam）。很快再见。你 本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。